even in summer canada isn't used to this
kind of heat
people are doing whatever they can to
stay cool
some flock to the beaches others are
stocking up on bottled water
in british columbia less than 40 percent
of homes have air conditioning
and demand for new units has skyrocketed
many in the region have never
experienced anything like it
we do get heat waves from time to time
every summer
the summers have been getting hotter but
you know it's never this bad
we've never experienced anything in the
40s in vancouver
dozens of people have died suddenly in
the past few days
deaths that are being blamed on the heat
wave
schools universities and vaccination
centers across the region are closed
the scorching temperatures are being
linked to a so-called heat dome
where high pressure zones trap the heat
what we're seeing happening with the
atmosphere is a very unusual pattern
where there's been intense high pressure
cut off from the global circulation
pattern
high pressure leads to sinking air and
sinking air warms up
we have this feature that's been cut off
from the circulation for a few days
that's the recipe for these dangerously
high temperatures
regional leaders are drawing a
connection between the unprecedented
temperatures
and the threat of climate change in this
instance i think the the big lesson
coming out of of the
past number of days is that the climate
crisis is not
a fiction it is absolutely real and if
you look i've had a briefing from the
wildfire service
yesterday and again today the entire
west coast of north america from baja to
alaska
is red-hot and awaiting what could be
another catastrophic fire season just
ahead of us as lightning
starts to come into the equations
authorities in canada and the u.s
are urging people to stay indoors drink
water
and check in on vulnerable friends and
relatives
the heat is expected to continue
throughout the week and more records
could be broken in the coming days
vinton molyneux
al jazeera